[Music]
5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy you loved it so much
the first time you'll probably love it
even more now
it's Formula One Track repaving
2.0 and it starts tonight remember the
fun of figuring out how to get around
Spring Mountain Sands and Las Vegas
Boulevard well starting at nine tonight
scheduled to run until nine Friday
morning eastbound Spring Mountain and
Westbound Sands will both be blocked and
unable to cross Las Vegas Boulevard now
there will still be access to the north
and southbound strip from both streets
now the Formula One folks say they're
going to take a break for a week but
then do it all over again starting at 9
00 PM Monday the 24th keeping the strip
Crossing shut down until 9 A.M Friday
July 28th
oh boy the second round of repaving will
also go around the strip Harman Koval
reportedly not as complicated as round
one was but I guess we'll all find out
together won't we now we want you to
share the online version of this story
with anyone you think might need to know
go to 8newsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
join the driving you crazy conversation
at traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com